[Música]
comienza el tour de francia la
competencia de ciclismo por etapas más
importante del mundo partido desde niza
con serias medidas de precaución cuando
el país galo enfrenta el rebrote del
hobby 19 hay grandes esperanzas para los
corredores latinos con el vigente
campeón el colombiano egan bernal
tenemos reporte desde niza
nueva masacre en colombia esta vez en el
departamento de antioquia fueron
asesinadas tres personas entre los 14 y
los 27 años ya son 9 crímenes de este
tipo desde el 11 de agosto en el país y
la mayoría de víctimas son jóvenes
y hay luto en el cine el actor chadwick
bousman falleció por cáncer de colon a
sus 43 años
chadwick que fue una insignia de la
comunidad afroamericana y le dio vida a
decenas de personajes incluyendo al
superhéroe de marvel pantera negra
comienza la mañana del sábado y también
las noticias en france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez iniciamos el informativo en
niza porque hoy parte del pelotón del
tour de francia en su edición 107 se
salvó de la cancelación la que es la
competencia ciclística por etapas más
importante del mundo sin embargo las
medidas de bioseguridad no son pocas
francia enfrenta los rebrotes de kobe 19
y algunas etapas atravesarán zonas rojas
del país por ello el comité de crisis e
interministerial del gobierno dictaminó
que un equipo debe retirarse si dos o
más de sus miembros dan positivo en un
periodo de siete días y es que francia
ya se acerca a los 305 mil contagios
vamos a misa con nuestra enviada
especial
natalia ruiz buen día para usted natalia
y cuáles son las medidas sanitarios del
tour
muy buenos dias angela pues las medidas
sanitarias son básicamente esta
mascarilla que es obligatoria
absolutamente para todas las personas
que sean personas por parte de la
logística de los equipos pero también
para el público sobre todo aquí en niza
que estamos en una zona roja donde el
virus circula activamente en a francia
habrá un ambiente diferente porque no
habrá autógrafos con los corredores
tampoco habrá oportunidad de tomarse
fotos con ellos no habrá posibilidad de
darles la mano así que todo se hace a
distancia también incluso para la prensa
pues hay restricciones para por ejemplo
hacer las entrevistas muchas de ellas se
van a hacer a distancia o habrá que
hacerlo con un boom para tener el
micrófono al menos unos dos metros de
distancia esas son las medidas y un
aforo de cinco mil personas no habrá
además público ni en la línea de llegada
ni en la línea de salida en ninguna de
las etapas así que esas son todas las
medidas que se han hecho aquí y
claramente pues además los equipos están
protegiendo muchísimo a sus corredores
este año por ejemplo cada corredor tiene
una habitación para él solo y ya no está
compartiendo precisamente para evitar
hacer evitar mayores contagios en caso
sobre todo que haya un caso positivo de
kobe 19 como usted bien lo decía el
equipo puede ser excluido si hay dos
casos positivos en el espacio de siete
días pero natalia de lo más emocionante
que se espera de la etapa de hoy
bueno pues en este momento están
realizándose la presentación de los
diferentes equipos en esta tarima que
ustedes tal vez alcanzan a ver a mis
espaldas se espera pues que ésta se le
dé la salida a esta primera etapa dentro
de una hora una etapa de 156 kilómetros
más bien plana así que será el momento
para los esprinters de aprovechar porque
en esta edición del tour hay muy pocas
oportunidades para los expedientes la
verdad es que sobre todo un tour de
francia' muy montañoso hay al menos
nueve etapas de montaña y cuatro de
ellas se van a terminar en ascenso así
que es más bien digamos un terreno
propicio para los escaladores entre
ellos pues llegan bernal el campeón
colombiano quien viene a defender su
título conseguido el año pasado y que
forma parte del equipo y neos ahí estará
muy bien escudado por dos otros
latinoamericanos el ecuatoriano richard
cara paz en su primer tour de francia y
también el costarricense andrey amador y
pues el gran duelo será entre
precisamente ese equipo y medios y el
jumbo isma que es el equipo holandés
donde está quizás el más grande
contendiente a éste
al título de bernal que es a primos
ahorro glitch así que esto lo que se
espera en esta carrera del día de hoy el
clima está más bien al tranquilo hace
bastante calor aquí a niza unos 28
grados y se espera que quizás hacia el
final de la carrera sobre las cinco y
media 6 de la tarde hora local haya de
pronto un poco de lluvia pues gracias a
ustedes no tal y cambiamos de tema
nueva masacre en colombia esta vez en el
departamento de antioquia y de nuevo las
víctimas fueron jóvenes entre los 14 y
los 27 años desde el 11 de agosto se han
registrado nueve masacres en diferentes
puntos del país veamos el siguiente
informe de álvaro cordero
colombia continúa sufriendo la espiral
de violencia provocada por las masacres
y en ellas los jóvenes siguen siendo los
principales afectados este viernes otras
tres personas de entre 14 y 27 años
grandes localidad del departamento de
antioquia en las últimas tres semanas
hasta nueve masacres han sacudido
diferentes zonas del país el 11 de
agosto fue la primera de estas masacres
en cali seguida de otras dos en nariño y
de tres masacres más entre el 20 y el 21
de agosto que causaron 16 víctimas
muchas de estas zonas son rutas clave
para el narcotráfico la última masacre
tuvo lugar mientras el presidente acudió
a cali tras la detención de dos
sospechosos de la matanza del 11 de
agosto a 5 adolescentes en esta ciudad
duke prometió justicia después de que su
gobierno recibiese duras críticas en las
últimas semanas
aquí el que la hace la tiene que pagar y
vamos a seguir esclareciendo estos
crímenes y vamos a seguir encontrando a
los culpables pero se requiere además
que la sanción que dé la justicia sea
ejemplar y sant a casi cuatro años de la
firma del acuerdo de paz colombia ve
como el fenómeno de las masacres que
padeció el país durante décadas está
regresando con fuerza en este 2020 a
pesar de los cinco meses de cuarentena
por la pandemia de coronavirus algo que
hace que ese tema que la paz pueda
descarrilar definitivamente
volvieron a las calles de santiago de
chile- las protestas contra el gobierno
seis meses después de su suspensión
forzosa por el coronavirus en la
emblemática plaza italia se llenó
nuevamente con 21 detenidos se saldó
este viernes cuando varias docenas de
personas se juntaron como lo hacían cada
viernes el desde el 18 de octubre del
los manifestantes respaldan el
plebiscito del 25 de octubre que
definirá un posible cambio de la
constitución
en eeuu miles de personas se congregaron
en washington este viernes cuando se
cumplieron 57 años del discurso tengo un
sueño del líder de derechos civiles
martin luther king esta vez exigieron el
fin de la violencia policial contra los
afroamericanos y el presidente de donald
trump hizo referencia a quienes se
manifestaron frente a la casa blanca
mientras el pronunciado el discurso que
cerró la convención republicana
promoviendo su agenda de orden los
calificó de matones vieron es cierto
cuando terminó la convención
los matones a las afueras de la casa
blanca
porque la alcaldesa demócrata de
washington dc es otra que no cree en la
ley el orden y saben le damos a
washington mucho dinero
pero la alcaldesa no hace un buen
trabajo al dirigirlo ella no dirige nada
y estas personas increíbles que fueron a
la convención desde todo el país y que
estuvieron ahí salieron para encontrarse
con un grupo de matones
y recuerden estos no eran manifestantes
pacíficos eran matones matones
y el actor de hollywood with bousman
falleció a la edad de 43 años el artista
un referente de la comunidad afro saltó
a la fama interpretando a iconos como
jackie robinson y james brown además de
dar vida al superhéroe de pantera negra
de marvel su familia dijo en las redes
sociales que luchó contra un cáncer de
colon durante los últimos años
un verdadero luchador que ahora descansa
con poder así es como los amigos
familiares y fanáticos de cha with
bousman dicen que recordarán al actor de
43 años llegó a la fama interpretando a
leyendas en la pantalla del cine grandes
como jackie robinson game round
trademark show pero fue su papel del rey
tacha la pantera negra el que lo
convirtió en un icono cultural al
protagonizar la primera película de
superhéroes de marvel con un elenco
predominantemente afro esto no es sólo
una película se ha convertido en algo
propio es un movimiento la gente está
entusiasmada con el aspecto cultural que
tiene la gente está emocionada de ver
algo nuevo
al anunciar en internet su fallecimiento
la familia bousman dijo que el honor de
su carrera fue interpretar a la pantera
negra pero detrás de escena hubo luchas
personales el nativo de carolina del sur
fue diagnosticado hace cuatro años con
cáncer de colon y como explicó su
familia continúa actuando y produciendo
mientras luchaba silenciosamente contra
la enfermedad desde washington hasta
hollywood han llegado las condolencias y
los homenajes la actriz halle berry
recordó a bozeman como un talento
inconmensurable que se inclinó hacia la
vida independientemente de sus batallas
personales y el aspirante a presidente
joe biden dijo que el verdadero poder de
boltzmann era inspirar a generaciones y
mostrarles a los niños y niñas
afroamericanos que pueden ser lo que
quieran la de chadwick fue una vida
tristemente corta pero que inspiró a
muchos a abrir sus propios caminos
en el informativo siga con nosotros en
france 24
[Música]